so now only americans
probably all of california is played through right here
is still very early about
nine hours is deducted from
those late in the evening so maritime
goes right back
yes you can definitely play
with black
at least more solidly somehow
you can of course small here again
playing small somehow with six runners
de 6
or 4 maybe
straight away now with
the loss of time the
agathe what I'm good about
well at least we have two runners
and he still has development potential
yeah that's nice
so
tempting maybe make g5
let's take it out again
yeah  looks optically nice but
not yet so easy maybe to get
ahead
yes of
course that can have several ideas
maybe also jumper d5 just
stuff here for pawns but I'm
going away from f4 here to then
come in here
if there's a jumper of 15 I have  also
maybe a few bishops c5 and
then we just play  so on I did
n't necessarily have to take away
yes I think there should have already spoken the
55 he
says he could also have
a look that one could yes that's why
after that I somehow have all the white
cases also go badly you got
six in
it so
the gain in
space well that's it
now relatively solid black can
now swap all the thermal baths here
we do with such also do big
differently so and now we have to
see how we get on here
that is still a nice position
with the two runners
yes okay not bad
so in the problem yes  that i can't get in with
the king on the steamer
so i would like to bring the king to the
four then maybe
try runner
b87 somehow provoked it as
he does at 5 and then i can arrive over 25
o'clock
yes of course
I would like to exchange  how free
yes well i go there anyway yes
also here namely in the runner
there he is really not bad he
plays at 4 kan  al do but
yes ok but that could not be good because
here in the pampa to send
or
now here I come your 1
springer c1 c2
who somehow plays the player
space well so completely convinced that is somehow
not yes you have to admit
maybe  fulfilled we get five
non-foggy runners g5 and then
the runner covers someone goes if he
tries to run out here now so yes
now that's actually quite
good how is it now if I if I
take four
or is it also
now where  I win time
runner who takes five maybe in
the one next to
the three then I can't
say exactly what time of
course a bit risky
well I might have until the
extinguisher in the mirror
well
check
now I'm standing here are weak
why am I that for you  non-reflective
yes just played badly
by fans share terrible
is somehow always nonsense this time
i can can he play any other way
dör  fer b4 king to five and 35
if I win them all well well
he will of course come then there too of
course I can't take them either
if you have good
material back here that's not a question
yeah dumb